one October changed so many lives but
for one local man he claims that night
changed him for the better Mark
Strickland shares his story of
motivation and the passion to give back
after he was shot Christian conseris has
his story five years later
I truly felt that if I wasn't where I
was
the bullet would hit somebody else and
where that person was laying in the way
they were laying
I don't feel that they would have made
it Mark Strickland says October 1st will
forever be a reminder of the mass
shooting in Las Vegas that changed his
life every day I wake up is a good day
his home decorated with Route 91 Music
Festival memorabilia he takes us back to
what he and his wife endured that night
there was a high heightened sense of
alertness I think the first thing I saw
someone who let some balloons go and it
sounded like fireworks going off in a
trash can and then the crowd didn't move
correctly the gunman fired more than one
thousand bullets into the crowd of 22
000 from the 32nd Floor of Mandalay Bay
we laid there for a little bit I
mentioned her that we should just hold
out and and we'll just wait for it to
clear and then we'll run away from all
the fire all the shooting
and
then I got shot
so today yeah because it immediately
hurt my arm and it peeled me off of her
I was actually on top of her
and it it kind of just peeled me right
off Strickland rushed to Desert Springs
Hospital for treatment looking down at
what had happened but and that was the
same time that the the drapes were still
hanging out of the Mandalay so we were
able to look over the Mandalay and look
at the to our you know our motel room
overlooked it to be able to kind of look
over the thing and go wow Strickland
says a conversation with a friend in law
enforcement helped him make a change in
his life at the age of 50 he turned his
focus on improving his mental and
physical health and enrolled in the Law
Enforcement Academy it was a great
experience
but at the heart at the same time you
think to yourself like
what am I doing this is hard all the
memorization all the the laws you know
it's like holy smokes this is rough but
then
I just did it
I hardened my
my focus and graduated Strickland now
proudly serving as a deputy Constable
with the Laughlin Township since 2018. a
second chance at a new life he says all
due to that night and the bullet he took
and now keeps as a reminder and a
motivation to give back it's not harder
you never really get over it you want to
live with it
[Music]